You don’t have to be an intellectual to
recognize how much season 8 sucked,
especially in comparison to the previous seasons.
Even casual fans recognized it, which the
official ratings clearly show.
My channel grew infamous for criticizing the
show in season 8
episode after episode for bad writing and
bad continuity and the general lack of logic.
It's not a secret that the show had a potential
to become the best show ever
(which it still is to me even with the horrible
final season
just because it had the absolute perfect 6
seasons.. yes season 7 was bad as well in
my opinion).
But Season 8 was a disaster.
Even actors, who earn money by excellent acting
skills,
can’t hide how disappointed they are with
season 8.
The story was rushed, character arcs destroyed.
There should have been 10 seasons.
Entire season 8 and the first part of season
9 should have been the long night,
war against the Night King, the second part
of season 9, and entire season 10 about Dany's
descent into madness and war against Cersei.
That's what HBO wanted as well.
They tried to convince them to do 10 seasons
but were lucky enough to even get this much
from D and D because they originally wanted
only 7 seasons.
In truth, HBO did not even get a full season,
they only got 3 extra episodes out of David
and Dan.
Their planned final season 7 was supposed
to have 10 episodes,
but when HBO convinced them to make 8 seasons,
they reduced the number of episodes from 10
to 7 for season 7 and had only 6 for season
8.
Anyways, in this video, we are going to talk
about every single error in season 8 episode
1.
Before we dive into the series, I just want
to highlight that all the criticism is directed
towards the showrunners and not towards actors
and the whole crew that did their best with
the horrible scripts they’ve got.
Actors and everyone involved in Game of Thrones
except for D&D deserve a standing OVATION
for their hard work over the years.
With that said, let’s get into it!
The season 8 premiere starts with a nice callback
and parallels to the season 1 premiere
which is quickly ruined with Tyrion's awful
joke.
When you don't have the capability to continue
Tyrion's brilliant arc from the earlier seasons,
dropping his IQ considerably ever since you've
passed the book material, this is what you
get.
Arya’s look at dragons gave me hope that
this season might have some story continuity
because she seemed so happy to see them.
Arya has always admired dragons and especially
the Targaryen Queen who rode them.
We learned that early on in season 2 episode
7 when Arya reveals to Tywin Lannister how
she adores Aegon the Conqueror's sisters,
Rhaenys and Visenya, with the latter being
her heroine.
I guess Arya kind of forgot her character
was supposed to like Dany.
Sansa’s look at dragons when they fly over
Winterfell gives me such a Littlefinger vibe,
she sees something so powerful and doesn’t
see a way not to bend her knee to such power
and it bothers her which we clearly see when
she greets Dany.
Still, Sansa said she's a slow learner, but
she learns,
then how come didn't she learn from Littlefinger
to give fake smiles and pretend she likes
Dany,
a reaction which should have been natural
in the first place
because the Dragon Queen has come to save
your home and your people.
When Jon and Bran reunited and Bran replied
to Jon's “You’re a man” with “Almost”,
I thought that reunion could have been done
better, but at that point, I was really looking
forward to how Bran’s story will play out,
I was excited that his story will finally
be somewhat exciting,
as, besides the tower of joy, his visions
and Hodor moment, Bran’s whole story was
rather boring.
In fact, it was so boring that the showrunners
did not even include Bran in the entirety
of season five.
Yes, that’s right, if you didn’t notice,
and I don’t blame you because the boy was
so boring,
Bran missed out the entire 5th season.
I thought season 8 had all the potential to
redeem him from being this boring weird guy
to an interesting three-eyed raven filled
with visions and all the warging we could
witness.
At the end, all Bran did was nothing, we saw
not one vision in season 8
and the only thing Bran warged was a few ravens.
And apparently, that’s the best story...
I remember before season 8 aired how we all
thought Bran’s powers would be crucial against
the Night King, after all, he did hype us
up by saying he needs to see better before
the Night King arrives.
Also, don't forget that tower of Joy vision
from the past in which he calls out to his
father Ned who hears him.
Well, all of that turned out to be of no significance
at all, it turned out to be nothing.
They really did subvert our expectations...
Northerners being unhappy with Dany’s arrival
at Winterfell makes no sense,
especially knowing they found out from Bran
that the Night King has a dragon in his army
now
and has broken the wall and already started
his Conquest over the North.
Instead of their smug faces, and worrying
about what dragons eat
and worrying about who has what title, they
should have cheered at the arrival of Dany,
her 2 dragons and her huge armies.
I’m glad Jon Snow shuts Sansa and all the
petty northern lords by saying that without
Dany and her army and her dragons, they wouldn’t
stand a chance … although I don't like his
statement “I had a choice.
Keep my crown or protect the north.
I chose the north” because that’s a lie.
After Viserion was shot down and when they
were on the boat going to Kings Landing with
a kidnapped wight, Dany gave him her word
that she will march her armies north
, and together they will destroy the Night
King.
Jon then said “thank you Dany” on which
she replied with that she doesn't remember
who called her that last time, perhaps her
unpleasant brother Viserys on which Jon replied
“Alright, not Dany.
How about my Queen?” and bent the knee,
not literally cause he was injured, but it
was pretty much it.
So when Jon says ''I had a choice, keep my
crown or protect the north'',
implying that Dany wouldn’t come if he did
not bend the knee -- is not true.
Guess D&D kinda forgot about the entire boat
scene and about Jon Snow not being able to
lie.
Season 8 is rushed and full of errors.
Anyways, Tyrion then also tries to explain
to these petty northern lords
that without Jon Snow and his successful travel
south to convince the dragon Queen to help
the North, they would all die.
This is followed by possibly the most stupid
question in the show, which is Sansa’s question
“May I ask, how are we meant to feed the
greatest army the world has ever seen?
While I ensured our stores would last through
winter, I didn’t account for Dothraki, Unsullied,
and two full-grown dragons.
What do dragons eat, anyway?”.
Really Sansa?
That’s your concern?
Will there be enough food until the Night
King attacks you tomorrow evening and what
do dragons eat?
Someone should sit her like a small child
and explain to her that not only does Winterfell
stand no chance against the Night King without
Dany, but they would not even have the weapons
that are able to kill the Night King’s army
that Dany provided from Dragonstone.
Dany literally has nothing to gain from this
allegiance with the North.
She’s seen the Night King, she knows she
will lose far more of her own men
than the North could ever provide her and
still she decides to save the North.
Dany should have pulled the Sansa move Sansa
did on Arya in season 7
about how without her the North didn't stand
a chance in a fight
and she should be on her knees thanking her.
At least Sansa does recognize in episode 2
that instead of being rude
she should have thanked her as soon as she
arrived.
but then in episode 3 and all
the remaining episodes she’s back to her
power-hungry and ungrateful attitude.
Total shitshow!
Tyrion says “if anyone survives the war
to come, we’ll have Jon Snow to thank.
He risked his life to show us the threat is
real.
Thanks to his courage we have brought the
greatest army the world has ever seen.
We have brought two large full grown dragons”.
Oh boy did you thank him after you all survived.
Not only did he save all of Westeros becuase
he convinced Dany to ally with the North and
defeat the Night King, but at the end he also
killed Dany to once again save Westeros from
Dany
(Mad Queen the shity writers made her mad
in the span of one episode)
who intended to liberate all of Westeros by
burning down everything and everyone.
They, especially Tyrion, thanked him real
good at the end, not even mentioning his name
at the great council when electing the King,
banishing him to the Wall.
To make things ever worse, the council was
literally made up of 90% of people who are
good with Jon, most being his friends and
family, most of whom knew Jon was the rightful
king.
When the question of the potential King came
in, nobody mentioned his name.
I'll go hard on that when we come to that
episode.
Anyways, back to the season 8 premiere.
Next we have a scene in which we see tons
and tons of dragonglass that they mined
and brought from Dragonstone to Winterfell
which is the only thing capable of killing
the Night King’s army, beside a few Valyrian
steel swords and fire.
What was the purpose of showing all of this
dragonglass
when in episode 3 we see that the entire Dothraki
cavalry who are on the first line of defence
or should I say offence don’t even have
Dragonglass weapons
and therefore 100 000 of them wouldn’t be
able to kill even one wight.
Lucky for them Melisandre showed up unexpected,
out of nowhere and set their ARAKHS on fire.
Best writing ever!
Is she really saying that the Queen who instead
of going for the Iron Throne and remaining
south
came to help her and the north is not a good
queen?
What?
Sansa and Tyrion conversation had some good
parts with the two discussing the last time
they saw each other, especially when Sansa
says Joffrey’s wedding had its moments and
both smiled.
When Tyrion says to her “Many underestimated
you.
Most are dead now”
is a nice little throwback to this Tyrion’s
statement way back in early seasons.
Really hurts to see how the showrunners made
Tyrion go from one of the smartest people
in the realm to a complete fool who believes
Cersei will send army north and Sansa here
mocks him for that.
They really thought we would be okay with
Sansa (who spent only a few years around Cersei)
understanding her character and motives better
than Tyrion (Cersei’s brother who spent
most of his life with her).. yeah, right..
Tyrion and his plans being so idiotic in recent
times is not a testament how Tyrion’s character
is stupid because it’s not,
Tyrion is one of the smartest people in this
world,
but its rather that showrunners were not smart
enough
to do his character after the book material
ran out.
Bran looking at him like, she’s right, I
saw it, you stupid.
How drastically they reduced Tyrion’s IQ
is still beyond me.
Every single of Tyrion’s plans in seasons
7 and 8 were so bad and devastating for Dany
that at one point (before being sent the leaks)
I was convinced Tyrion was a traitor working
for Cersei.
I even made a few videos about it.
Jon-Arya reunion was actually alright for
some part.
In my opinion, it could have been done better,
but compared to everything else, it was alright.
The hug and the first part of the conversation
was done just fine,
but then Arya goes on to stay on Sansa’s
side instead of supporting Jon
who is obviously right about them needing
Dany.
Also that Arya’s now already infamous line
“Sansa is the smartest person I’ve ever
met”
is such a punch to the face to all of us.
Don't get me wrong, I’m okay with Sansa
being smart,
she’s had years and years of learning to
play the Game of Thrones,
learning from some of the best, including
Cersei and Littlefinger,
but would the one who knows the game really
act like that towards Dany?
Can you see someone really politically smart
act like that towards their allies who came
to save them?
Anyways, Arya saying Sansa is the smartest
person she’s ever met is plain stupid
especially when you remember she met and spent
a good amount of time
with none other than mighty Tywin Lannister.
Then again, Arya is not very good with words
which we learn later when she says for Dany
“I know a killer when I see one” right
after Dany burned down entire Kings Landing,
killing one million people.
Good call, Arya!
So yeah, Arya saying for Sansa to be the smartest
person she’s ever met makes no sense,
not only because Arya definitely met people
smarter than Sansa,
but also because there was nothing Sansa displayed
in season 7 or 8 that would lead Arya to say
that.
Sansa almost fell for Littlefinger’s game
in season 7.
That’s right, it wasn’t Sansa manipulating
him, it was once again her being manipulated
during the entire season until Bran told her
behind the scenes what’s Littlefinger really
about and what he did.
This was confirmed by an actor who plays Bran
Stark as well as by the showrunners.
So there’s that.
Also if Jon’s “how did you sneak up on
me” was meant to foreshadow Arya sneaking
up on the Night King two episodes later in
this same place, that’s not smart foreshadowing,
because here Jon is alone,
so it’s explainable and logical that a year
or two of training to become a stealthy assassin
would result in her being able to sneak up
on a person who is alone,
but her sneaking up on the Night King who
is surrounded by all the White Walkers
and his entire army of the dead, yeah that’s
bs!
And btw as you can see, there is literally
nothing Arya could have used to come close
to the Night King without being spotted nor
something to use to jump on him the way she
did.
Their reunion ends with Arya saying to Jon
something along the line
“don’t forget you are my and Sansa’s
family with Jon’s face being like “what?”.
At a time I thought Bran probably told Arya
and Sansa about Jon’s parentage
and that’s why Arya says this but no, we
see them learn that later from Bran
(instead of learning it from Jon which made
me so angry).
So her saying this to Jon Snow here makes
no sense.
Down south, things are not going great either.
Euron tells Yara his ship Silence is full
of mutes, thank god they are still holding
continuity in some parts of the story, oh
nevermind, they later kind of forgot they
had no tongues when they yelled and shouted.
Euron’s complete character is just a joke,
I honestly feel bad for the actor who was
so pumped to play Euron because he’s a big
fan of the books and expected his character
to be like in the books,
one of the most evil and badass characters,
telling news reporters how his character is
going to make both Joffrey and Ramsay look
like little babies.
That’s was before he got the scripts.
Poor guy...
Okay, that's too many errors for one video,
we'll have to stop right here.
Part 2 for season 8 episode 1 errors is coming
tomorrow.